I never in a million years would have
thought that I would direct a big film
for Disney and so I kind of was thrown
into the fire it took six years to make
Brother Bear a lot of times that first
version is
horrible you have to have the ability to
kind of step out of yourself and go back
to what was the original core Vision
yeah this is so visually stunning you're
putting your Anatomy skills on full
display here if you were to draw this
creature what's important to highlight
what
isn't
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to another
really special episode of animators
react because we are joined by a special
guest Aaron Blaze hey it's an honor to
have you on the couch it's an honor to
be here I've watched this show so many
times I'm I'm really excited Aon could
you tell us a little bit about yourself
yes I've been an animator for 35 years
and uh 21 of those years I was at Walt
Disney Company and it was there that I
worked on The Rescuers Down Under I
worked on a Aladdin Beauty and the Beast
The Lion King Pocahontas Mulan and I
directed brother bear the heck of a
resume had a lot of movies yes boy I'm
intimidated Peter is joining us as well
Peter by far has animated more
characters and creatures than anybody
here at Corridor so I cannot think of a
a better co-host today than Peter to
join us so Aon you're known for doing a
lot of nature based drawings and animal
based drawings I was always fascinated
with animals and animal anatomy and
comparative Anatomy back in the ' 80s
there were artists like Robert baitman
and Guy kak these were really big
painters and so I took that with into my
animation and so once I learned how to
animate to actually take my fascination
of animals and take those and now I
could go through the physiology and and
figure out movement and all that kind of
stuff that really hooked me and you took
that knowledge of animals and you
applied it to Beast and Beauty and the
Beast you applied it to Raja and Aladdin
and you applied it to Nala and The Lion
King so coming off of Lion King you
ended up moving from animator to
director what happened was after we
finished Mulan We had a state of the
union of the studio and the heads of the
studio would just get up and say hey
this is what we got in development and
they talked about this film called bears
and me being the animal guy that I am I
just went o my ears perked up and we
were coming off of the success of the
Lion King Michael Eisner realized that
there was no other animal film in
development and so he wanted a big North
American epic and so Tom Schumacher who
was the head of the studio I called him
up and said hey you know I'd really love
to be involved in this movie in some way
let me be a character designer and he
brought up he goes well have you ever
thought about directing and I never had
I never in a million years would have
thought that I would direct an you know
a big film for Disney and um matter of
fact several of the films that I had
started on the the original director
that started the film would get replaced
Oh by new directors and they would
finish the film I was like I don't uh
I'm on a good path as an animator and I
don't know if I want to put myself out
there but I remember going home and
talking to my wife I talked to my father
my father remember him saying you know
if you don't do this you're always going
to be wondering what if and so I decided
to go ahead head and do it and that
became Brother
Bear we we went to Alaska several times
and researched and so all this stuff
comes from direct research there's a
scene where they're up on a hillside
where they're leaning into the wind and
the wind's holding them up we were in
Alaska in a place called Turning an arm
which is this little funnel Valley that
the wind just gets compressed and just
flies down our producer Chuck Williams
and myself got up on the edge of this
cliff and just kind of leaned into the
wind holding we're holding our jackets
out and we're like we got to put this in
the movie so so that became part of the
movie you know we talk about going on
these research trips and people are like
why don't you just go on Google but
there's something about you go to the
place and you you smell the smells and
you go through these experiences that
spark ideas that that become part of the
story so Erin I would assume that if
you're making an entire film about Bears
first you would need to closely study
real bears and figure out how they move
what if you were to draw this creature
what would you bring to the page what
would you ignore what what's important
to highlight what isn't when you're
looking at four-legged animals 90% of
the time their pattern is consistent
look at the head and then the over you
got the overlap of the neck in front of
the head you got the overlap of that
line of the shoulder see the line of the
shoulder in front of the neck and then
the transition into the bellies and then
you go into the hips where the leg comes
up you got the pelvis and the back legs
and you got the tail so it's that it's
those six elements that I'm I'm always
talking about and you see that with
every animal you know when you start
those films you already have the the
general knowledge of this is a
four-legged pattern and then you study
the animal enough to understand the
anatomy so like with a grizzly bear
they're huge and heavily muscled in the
shoulders and they got lots of blubber
on them so you know where a cat you know
moves really fluid a grizzly bear goes
through the same pattern but
it's you know and with with each step
you see a a jiggle in the in the meat
and the fat and all these things that's
what makes a grizzly bear grizzly bear
so you're confident in your ability to
animate these animals but what about
your confidence in being a firsttime
director I thought I knew how to make an
animated movie I'd made seven of them at
this point or been a part of making
seven of them and so I kind of was
thrown into the fire I came in early and
I was doing a lot of storyboarding cuz
we would storyboard these movies three
or four times before we'd start making
them you want to make sure you're you're
making the right film right we cut it
together we cut sound we cut scratch
dialogue we you know try to make it a
movie and we and we cut it to the length
of that we want to see it a lot of times
that first version is
horrible well it's a beautiful thing
about animation you know nothing set in
stone the beauty of this is is that we
haven't made the film yet all we've done
is storyboard so you take it down you
break it apart you fix the parts that
are broken you keep the parts that are
working you put it back together again
and you watch it again oh now it's less
broken you have to have the ability to
kind of step out of yourself and go back
to what was the original core vision and
what was that original spark what was
was that original thing and how have we
drifted off of that we knew it was a
transformation we knew it was a
character being flawed in the beginning
and becoming whole in the end but we
weren't quite sure what was the vehicle
that we're going to tell this in and so
9/11
happened and after 9/11 happened there
was this huge influx of hate crimes
against Muslim people in the United
States and it really affected me in a
way that I started thinking about you
know these people that are just living
their lives and I remember going in and
sitting down with the story team and
talking about this and just became this
big emotional discussion and so we put
it into the story not obviously in
direct ways but if you watch the story
it really is you know you you have to
see through another's eyes in order to
understand
[Music]
them so we're watching the
transformation right now this is after
Kenai has killed a bear responsible for
the death of his brother we knew we
wanted a big visually crazy
transformation to happen here but we had
no idea how to do it and guy named
Richie Chavez who was just an amazing
artist he took about six weeks and in
pastels he did these story boards of key
moments all the way through the sequence
which turned into this yeah this is so
visually stunning oh thanks what was
nice on top of this so we we had that
that was the visual side of things we
wanted this to be a song as well so Phil
Collins who did the music he wrote the
lyrics All About You know seeing through
another's eyes and seeing a new but we
wanted to have this spiritual kind of
ethereal kind of feel so him actually
singing English words kind of killed it
so we took his lyrics and we sent them
to the University of Alaska where they
translated it into Inu H wow and then we
brought that and we went to the
Bulgarian women's choir huh and we had
them sing it phonetically and so the
voices you you hear in here is the
Bulgarian women's choir singing in it oh
that's crazy
that's a lot of crazy collaboration yeah
it was such a cool synergistic thing
until the end product was this really
spiritual
feel after the transformation sequence
you have an interesting choice here
which is to change the aspect ratio of
the entire film you know it goes out to
a a 244 aspect ratio it goes really
widescreen before that it's 185 so the
only way you can do that and and get the
full effect of it is that in the
beginning you're just ending up with a
box in the middle of your screen oh wow
and they were afraid that people were
going to think they weren't getting the
whole movie and some people did complain
about that that makes sense though
because I imagine the effect you wanted
is to enlarge it and so as opposed to
just cropping the other stuff right you
make it smaller and then ex blow it up
and you know everything's done for a
reason and so and it all it's all in the
service of story so the whole point of
the story the theme of the story is to
see through another's eyes to to
understand the world from another point
of view and so we thought when keenai
turns into a bear he's literally seeing
the world in a completely bigger
different way we literally made his view
bigger and the other thing too it's not
just the aspect ratio but the pallet
really the First Act of the film The
Pallet is all toned down muted colors
that's a really powerful effect the
audience is actually seeing the film in
a new way now too oh Jee I think he's
looking over here speed it this way no
no no this way the Moose great
characters they're voiced by Rick
morenus and Dave Thomas back in the 70s
Canada had their version of Satur night
life it was called satv Welcome to the
great white North I'm Bob mcken this is
my brother Doug Rick Moranis and Dave
Thomas they came up with these two
characters that are kind of like these
Canadian beer drinking guys my directing
partner was Bob Walker who's who's
Canadian and we loved them as kids they
were super funny and so by the time we
were making these moose that lived up in
the Canadian region we're like oh we got
to get Bob and DG we got to get Bob and
so when you hear them talk it's the same
skit well G you're one big beaver don't
kid me the the characters beautifully
animated by Bruce Johnson and Tony
Stanley look at the geometry on those
antlers oh my God I can't imagine now
one of the things you're going to notice
is they're Rock
Solid cuz the antlers were built in 3D
and then they would place them and then
they trace over them and then they would
draw the inbetween so it was a that was
a mixture of of computer and and
handrawn but in a completely unique way
well it totally fits you know drawing
the inbetween by hand really sells it I
am so blown away by these painted
backgrounds we had an artist in our
group named JG and this is his natural
painting style when he goes out and does
Landscapes this is what he paints like
and so this is what I paint like yeah
can't help it by and large it was all
traditionally painted in acrylic do
these background paintings exist like in
an art gallery anywhere no they there's
a place called the animation research
library or the way we we call it the
morg and it's all temperature controlled
it's about 50° in there they keep every
it's really dry there's no humidity and
everyone has to wear gloves every piece
of art all the way from Steamboat Willie
to now is housed in that in that
warehouse wow and it's all broken up by
film imagine how much art there must be
yeah and it's not just a production art
it's all the development art it's all
the storyboard art it's everything
there's an estimate that with each
feature film there's about a million
pieces of art that are created with
story sketches layout drawings all that
sort of thing and so imagine 100 movies
with a million pieces of art so there's
100 million pieces of Art in that
building it's crazy I'm here tonight to
present the award for best animated
feature Brother Bear was nominated for
best animated feature we went up against
Finding Nemo so we didn't stand a chance
so Nemo Nemo won and it was just it was
awesome to be there and everyone says
you know it's just awesome to be
nominated it really
was so you have this you have this whole
film you've made this whole huge art
Endeavor did you want to keep directing
Brother Bear it took six years to make
Brother Bear it didn't perform as big as
we had hoped but it it it wasn't a bomb
though either right after Brother Bear
came out that's that was when the
transition going into 3D started
happening and so right about this time
Disney they decided to kind of
consolidate they shut down the Florida
Studio they laid off 300 50 people they
laid off everybody except about 10 of us
and I had a new contract to develop a
new movie it was going to be a CG film
it was a film called King of the elves
but then
2005 uh my wife Karen was diagnosed with
breast cancer and you can imagine you
know trying to direct a movie and then
having someone that's as sick as that it
just doesn't work very well and it got
to the point she wasn't getting better
eventually in 2007 she passed away and I
was just absolutely devastated I went
from this guy that was loving film
making to just dreading getting up every
day I've been with Disney for 21 years
and uh I quit I loved loved loved
working for Disney but I said I need to
I need to find myself again I don't know
who I am I mean my first the first thing
I am is an artist and I I don't I'm not
even that and I I need to find that
again I thought about my wife that had
passed away I wanted to do something
that would make her proud that's when I
started creature art teacher and now
we're slowly transitioning back into
making movies but making our own movies
we're doing a short film it's a
10-minute film called snow bear
ironically enough and I swear I did not
plan this but it's another bear I swear
we went from Brother Bear to snow
bear and I wanted to create something
that we could create on our own cuz I
wanted to do the backgrounds I wanted to
do everything and I started digging deep
into some of my emotional baggage so it
created this character that's lonely
looking for a friend uh wandering the
Arctic and so he makes a snow bear MH
this is all just me sitting down and
doing the backgrounds doing the
animation and just plotting along one
drawing at a time you're putting your
Anatomy skills on full display here I've
seeing a lot of like subtle flexes
happening here yes exactly that's what
we've been working on for the last what
year and a half I guess our platform is
education after we make it we want to
show people how we made it and so how do
you make an animated short will let me
show you creature art teer.com yeah is
where we have all the lessons they're
very affordable very accessible yes I
just don't want people going into debt
and I you know we really want people to
learn and over 700 hours of content okay
I'm going to enlist in your class I've
decided this is great stuff right now
from a creative standpoint I'm happier
now than even then back then and it took
the death of a soulmate to push you in a
direction that takes you to a place that
you'd never expect yeah if we can make
the world a little bit better through
our art then that's that's what we want
to
do